another windy day in scotland
as always howie nicholsby a second
generation kiltmaker
cycles to work in the traditional
scottish men's garment
he enjoys the 30 kilometer coastal ride
near the firth of fourth estuary
just north of edinburgh i feel scottish
first
you are who you are from where you're
born and the
society that is around you and
scottish society is different from
english welsh and irish society
we have our own culture music language
art history that's what makes a culture
howie's father taught him how to make
kilts decades ago
these days howie designs and sells the
traditional scottish clothing items
around the world
the eu is a key market for him
seven and a half meters of fabric are
needed to make a single kilt
so that's how much material is in a
man's kill
howie voted in favor of scottish
independence in the 2014 referendum
he does still believe scotland should be
an autonomous country
but brexit and the pandemic have given
him doubts
he thinks independence could be risky
dividing society
and even his family it is becoming
sensitive again
and the disharmony that created within a
family unit
so that spread right across the whole of
scotland and
into england we head to the capital and
seat of the scottish parliament in
edinburgh
to see what people think about
independence
many here tell us they'd be happy to
leave britain
we have assets great assets and i think
throughout this as well interestingly
especially in edinburgh being the
capital
there's been a real community feel great
entrepreneurship
so i i think that that will be to the
benefit um
of our country well i think scotland is
a lot more liberal as a country rather
than england and
those choices um we can uh
make on our making our own really and
not have to um
get onto westminster for approval which
i don't think we get
others meanwhile feel that after the
brexit turmoil
scotland needs to let the dust settle i
think we should stay in the union
um i think that brexit i didn't want
brexit and that has been um
you know an absolute nightmare so why
would you want to break up a union
that's you know hundreds and hundreds of
years
i think it would cost a lot of money i
think it would be terrible for the
economy and i don't think scotland can
afford to be independent
we have a devolved parliament they have
taxation powers
they have quite a lot of power so i
don't see what else they want
many scots living near the
anglo-scottish border
some 100 kilometers south of edinburgh
oppose the idea of independence
john elliott's cattle farm overlooks the
cheviot hills that straddle the border
many people here work and shop over in
england
we're aware that um that
if there was any trade barriers it would
be very difficult
in this area because at the moment uh
a lot of the the the communities are
integrated between england and scotland
in this area and i think that's
would be a shame if there's any sort of
barrier between between the two
john elliott runs the farm together with
his father
they sell aberdeen angus cattle for
breeding to the eu and elsewhere
so international trade is important but
to them
keeping scotland in britain is even more
important
i personally voted in the eu referendum
to
to remain within europe but i think it
was asked the question now would i
want to go through it all again and and
to try and achieve
to get back into europe i think my
answer would be no i think
i think the the union at the moment
seems to be doing okay
uh we've had a lot of the pain and got
through it
kiltmaker howie nicholsby has thought
long and hard about the possible
economic consequences of scottish
independence
and he thinks independents will have to
wait for now
i only want an independent scotland that
is good for scotland and the scottish
people
and it feels too much for its
politicians and politics
and party rivalry as opposed to thinking
on a business level
and strategy and plan of how it's
actually going to work
the drive for independence will continue
to impact scots like howie nicholsby and
his family
and brexit has only served to stoke the
fire
you